hi I'm selfish Laci with et and today I
want to reintroduce you to one of my
favorite young artists Raylan now it's
been five years since ray first caught
Blake Shelton's ear on the voice and
since then so much has changed she's
really been working hard honing her
craft writing and now she is finally
ready to release her first full-length
album called wild horse only I had the
chance to sit down with Ray for some
real talk about what it actually takes
to make it after the voice and what
she's learned about Fame from Blake
Shelton was trying to figure out if I
wanted my record to be just a
self-titled record because it's my first
record but I love it when a body of work
has a name my mom told me about this
poem that she had just found that my
grandma wrote about my mother and it was
titled wild horse and it was talking
about how my mom was the good kind of
crazy and when she read me this poem I
begin to cry because it was just so
perfect I was like oh my god that's
gotta be the title to my record and I
was like but now I got to write the song
to heal bigger jumping
and I come for her
you co-wrote 11 out of the 12 so myself
how personal is each song every song if
you asked me about it I could tell you
where I was and I wrote it and why I
wrote it and every song is your story
this record really just shows where I've
been in the last four years I've changed
so much as a woman and I've learned so
much about myself and my record really
showcases that you know some of these
songs are definitely not in the head
space that I am in now you know but they
were when I wrote them and it's really
cool to look back and see oh my god I
was so sad when I wrote that song like
or oh my gosh like I was so sassy when I
read that song you know and I've changed
a lot as a person in these last five
years I was on the voice when I was 17
years old now you're on the same label
as black but there's no collaboration on
your album first of all there was no
songs that felt like we can do together
cuz I'm not gonna do like love duet with
him they'll be so weird I'd like my dad
/ brother what would a collaboration
between Raylan and Blake Shelton's
sounds like chaos I think Blake Shelton
plays such a huge role in Raylan's story
it's really impossible to tell without
him not only has he been a mentor to her
but he's been a touring companion and a
real life friend him and girlfriend Gwen
Stefani were even on hand when Raylan
married her husband Josh Davis in 2016
due to scheduling unfortunately Blake
couldn't be with us in person for the
interview but I was able to connect with
him and ask a few questions like why out
of all of the artists he's worked with
on the voice has he bonded so strongly
with write the very first time I ever
heard raelynne's voice was sitting in my
red chair on the only on the show I
heard this voice start to sing and it
just it was familiar but it was also
like something I never heard before
I hit my button and I turned around and
instantly looked like a star that's one
of the times that Adam had been most
upset with me was whenever Raylan chose
me to be her coach I guess you could say
she's definitely uh you know my personal
favorite I just feel a bond with her
that you know is unexplainable she's a
star is what she is and a great friend
and a good kid and I just want to see
the best that can possibly happen for
happen and that's why I'm glad to see
her getting the recognition that she
deserves with the love triangle on this
new album it's going to be incredible
one thing that I could say what like is
he's never changed he doesn't let
anything affect him we went in ate lunch
when I was like 19 in LA we walked out
of the restaurant and there was like all
these people outside and I was like how
do you handle this egos you just handle
it he's like you just you know have a
smile on your face you talk to him like
that's one thing that I take from him is
that's like you just can't let any of
that change you you know you always have
to keep people around you that are gonna
keep you grounded
are there any habits or blake isms that
you've picked up from being on the road
of them oh my god I don't know I picked
anything up I just know that like every
time we're on stage we just want to
laugh I don't know why like cuz it's
just he's just like a goober it's just
like going up there with your big
brother or at one time we were singing
and he yells out my part like I supposed
to come and go that's right and he just
yelled up that's right I'm like that's
my part like and then we just started
laughing he's just awesome
that's a hunky tone where the boots
don't fall 9:1 yeah so before you were
touring with Blake you had also toured
with Miranda Lambert are you guys still
in touch oh my god of course I love her
her record is so great so you just
celebrated your first wedding
anniversary yes a lots changed for you
as well what's been the best part of the
first year and the hardest part of the
first year the best part is just having
your best friend with you all the time
and like when you say I do that bond
just like strengthens so much more we're
one like I have this person that's going
through it with me you know my husband
joined the service and he's been gone
for a little bit and that that part's
been hard because I just I feel like a
piece of me is gone
24/7 like like when something happens
after write it in a letter I'm like are
we back to Noah and Allie days like this
is just crazy you know
at the end of the day I'm married to an
incredible man and he's the my best
friend and yeah we might irritate each
other sometimes but who doesn't you just
announced your first headlining tour the
brave two or what can we expect fun I am
so excited I like I told my man girls I
don't care if even 50 people show up
what would probably there's more than
but I'm saying like this tour is just
gonna be a hundred percent me I wanted
it to be a big dance party it's gonna be
like we're gonna have like an opening DJ
for 30 minutes and then I'm gonna go on
for an hour and we're gonna dance party
at the end like it's gonna be nonstop
fun Cibola see you shake it Dennis come
on never say [ __ ] no singing show
reality show is gonna make you a
superstar what makes you a superstar is
what you do after that right after the
voice I went straight back to Nashville
started riding Monday through Friday
then it got my butt in a van and
traveled all across the US and went to
every country radio station in the u.s.
got ready and gas stations like that's
how it was like you have to do that
groundwork and I did an interview with
Adam Levine and Blake and it was so true
what Adam said he said everybody who's a
suit wants to be singer now just wants
to have instant success he said but it
took me 10 years it took Blake 10 years
to get where we are today anyway who
asked me should I do the voice I'm like
of course you should do the voice you
should learn from that experience you
should get fans I said but it doesn't
stop when the voice ends like you're not
a superstar at that point you have so
much more work to do it's just the
beginning I'm the walking example of it
it's been five years and now I Know Who
I am and and it's taken me a little bit
but that I think that's the beauty of of
when you really want something and it's
your dream and it's your passion you're
going to make it happen thank you guys
so much for watching be sure to click
Subscribe for all the best from
Entertainment Tonight and check out
Raylan's new album wild horse it is out
March 24